It's really important in this era of constant
sort of political scandal and in reality it's
almost an era of constant scandal fatigue.
Not to let the storylines of this administration
just
ight away without followup.
And ne of those stories is the wall, right?
Donald Trump's wall with exico, which we now
learned can be defeated with $100 saw available
at any hardware store.
So remember, onald Trump promised a wall across
the entire us exico border by the end of his
irst term, obviously a joke.
It's not going to happen.
It always was a joke.
It was never going to happen.
But onald Trump and his followers are trying
to claim that the wall is being built.
Trump says it's being built.
The truth is that there was previously approved
money to repair and replace.
Some aged parts of the wall and it is being
done with the version of the wall that onald
Trump, uh, likes or says is quote virtually
impenetrable.
So another element of this is the strength
of the wall and the, uh, ways in which the
wall can be defeated.
And it turns out that the wall Trump wants
to build, uh, is a total farce.
It is not virtually impenetrable.
It is very easily defeatable.
And in fact, border agents and officials recently
told the ashington post that $100 saw that
you can get at any hardware store can cut
right through the wall.
Some of these rebuilt, repaired wall sections.
We're done with Trump's version of the wall,
which has steel bollards and it has a hirty
foot, uh, a series of hirty foot tall panels.
So smugglers have been carrying around a hundred
dollars saw and just cutting through the steel
bollards.
And then you push the panels forward and you
walk right through Donald Trump's virtually
impenetrable wall, which he called the rolls
Royce of walls.
It sounds more like the Trump tower of walls,
given its shoddy nature.
I think that's the better analogy, uh, for
the, uh, uh, quality of the construction that
I would use.
Now, unfortunately, this is what happens when
you let xenophobia blind you and your followers.
You end up putting all of your eggs in ne
basket.
In this case, it's the basket of a wall that
doesn't really work and in the basket of obsolete
technology that does nothing to address the
underlying reality of why people are trying
to come to the nited States, which is really
what we should be working on if we want to
solve this problem.
But it turns out that it can also be defeated
with $100 tool.
Look at any time in history and look at the
various ways, the myriad ways in which walls
have been defeated.
Look at Troy, look at, um, I'm forgetting
other historical examples offhand, but there
are many of them now you can argue the point
of the wall isn't that it has to actually
be impenetrable.
It just has to delay people long enough that
border patrol can show up.
Wait a econd.
You're shifting the goalposts to say that
we're going to spend wenty billion, wenty
five billion, whatever it's going to be, and
it's not meant to stop $100 saw.
It's just meant to delay people so that border
patrol can show up.
Doesn't our river also delay people long enough
that border patrol should be able to show
up in all cases because we've already got
that at much of the border.
The wall is not pragmatic.
The wall is a monument to xenophobia.
It's a monument to political promises and
it's not being built.
That's the most important thing.
It is quite literally a boondoggle, and by
the way, I'll remind you, it's not just a
hundred dollars saw that can defeat the wall.
The wall has been scaled and passed over as
well, but this is also ultimately not about
that.
This is an example of feelings over facts.
The fact that the wall will cost tens of billions
of dollars and not solve anything.
The fact that the wall can be defeated with
$100 tool, the facts don't matter.
The feeling that Trump has to get by seeing
Trump talk about the wall and promise the
wall of Trump being big and strong and powerful,
and that it'll stop people from coming in
in some complete fantasy world that supersedes
the facts and the people who shout about we
should pay attention to facts over feelings
are the ones who are being destroyed by their
own feelings while ignoring the facts.
And yet again, another embarrassment, $100
saw defeating the wall.
The wall is barely a conversation anymore
for Republicans, of course, because it was
yet another ne of Donald Trump's massive failures.
But we're not going to forget
about it.